[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez le cdi
le contrat à durée indéterminée le
contrat à vie tant que personne ça veut
dire la sécurité du travail
en tant qu'entreprise ça veut dire
garder ses salariés ça a l'air génial
sauf que ça ça ça marchait pour le monde
d'avant aujourd'hui tout s'accélère et
entendre personne on imagine plus rester
dans la même entreprise toute sa vie en
tant qu'entreprise non plus on imagine
pu faire la même chose toute sa vie donc
au final on en arrive à la même
conclusion
mais pas pour les mêmes raisons le cdi
c'est plus le saint graal
le cdi c'est plus l'unique manière
d'envisager de répondre à nos besoins
sauf que le cdi c'est la partie immergée
de l'iceberg émerger au fond ce qu'on
dit c'est qu'on est face à une profonde
transformation du rapport au travail
alors moi aussi j'entends tout ce qu'on
dit sur les générations y z qui sont
instables tout ça tout ça
ok certes mais quand je vois les
chiffres de la dares qui disent que 90%
des nouvelles embauches se font en cdd
en contrat à durée déterminée je me dis
qu'on peut se partager la responsabilité
je me dis que les pouvoirs publics je me
dis que les entreprises elles sont pas
pour rien dans cette histoire
après
qui de la poule ou de l'oeuf je sais pas
c'est une autre question
toujours est il que la combinaison de
ces nouvelles aspirations
avec la transformation du marché du
travail
ça fait que qu'on le veuille ou non tous
ici on fera pas le même métier dans la
même boîte toute notre vie et ça va même
plus loin que ça on fera des métiers
qu'on connaît pas 60% les métiers de
2030 qui n'existe pas encore 2030 c'est
pas de la science-fiction 2030 c'est
demain d'ailleurs on voit bien il ya
quelques années on n'avait jamais
entendu parler de community manager
jamais de grosses à coeur aujourd'hui
c'est notre réalité donc qui sait ce
qu'on fera demain
tout ça au final ça nous pose des
nouvelles questions sur le travail
on voit bien qu'il se passe des trucs
qui se passait pas avant pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière
je buvais un verre avec une amie et me
dit tu sais pas ce qui m'arrive et on va
proposer un cdi c'est horrible je crois
que je peux négocier un cdd c'est le
monde à l'envers
alors je vous dis pas que c'est tout le
monde je vous dis pas que c'est la
majorité
je vous dis que c'est un sacré signal
faible pareil pour les reconversions je
vous parle pas des reconversions où ça
fait 20 ans qu'on fait le même métier on
est au milieu de sa vie pro et on se dit
que pour la deuxième moitié on ferait
bien autre chose je vous parle de ces
reconversions qui arrive avant 30 ans et
c'est souvent des reconversion radicale
et autour de moi des gens comme ça j'en
vois plein et puis enfin il ya tous ceux
qui subissent qui subissent pas ce
qu'ils trouvent pas de job dans leur
secteur qu'ils subissent
parce que là où ils sont
dans leur entreprise ils souffrent et
qui n'arrivent pas bouger parce que
c'est pas si simple
alors tout ça c'est pas générationnel
c'est contextuel on est face à une
tendance de fond qui concerne tout le
monde et qui va en s'amplifiant
c'est la fin des carrières linéaires le
problème c'est qu'à ça il n'y a pas été
préparés du coup ça a créé de la tension
sacré de la tension au niveau des
entreprises et au niveau des individus
alors au niveau des entreprises c'est
assez facile à comprendre là des
nouveaux comportements qu'on comprend
pas qu'on n'a pas anticipé du coup on
n'arrive pas à attirer et fidéliser ses
talents ses collaborateurs là et puis en
plus on doit anticiper que les métiers
de notre boîte vont changer on sait pas
trop dans quelle direction on sait pas
qui pourra les faire complexe au niveau
des individus c'est un peu plus
compliqué à expliquer parce qu'au final
et juste autant de vécu quatre personnes
moi par exemple quand je suis arrivé
dans le marché du travail
j'ai fait trois jobs en trois ans c'est
pas du tout ce que j'avais anticipé
quand j'ai démarré tout allait bien j'ai
démarré dans une boîte qu'ils aient un
truc qui me passionnait dans la
formation c'était génial je me suis dit
que j'avais trop de chance parce qu'il y
avait plein de gens autour de moi qui
avais pas ça sauf qu'en fait au bout
d'un moment je me suis rendu compte que
ça suffisait pas ça suffisait pas parce
que l'environnement de travail
la boîte et ne convenait pas à les
pointer pouvait pas mettre des photos
sur son bureau
ça paraît anecdotique mais pour moi
c'était important
alors du coup je pars est c'est à ce
moment là j'ai commencé à me poser des
questions sur le travail
je me suis demandé si j'étais fait pour
l'entreprise
et du coup je me suis demandé si je
mettais pas planter deux voies alors
j'avais pas toutes les réponses
du coup j'ai partie au mexique
rien à voir pas du tout un choix de la
raison un choix du coeur comme on dit du
coup une fois sur place j'ai pris le
premier job que je trouvais c'était dans
une boîte qui a d'elle et les les
entreprises européennes à s'implanter là
bas et mon boulot c'était un truc hyper
administratif alors l'ambiance géniale
que ce soit dans l'entreprise ou
ailleurs au mexique je sais pas si vous
connaissez mais c'est assez sympa je
m'éclatais je m'éclatais mais au bout
d'un moment je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait c'était pas suffisant je
pouvais pas juste venir tous les jours
au même endroit pour faire un truc qui
vous plaisait pas à nouveau
je suis parti je suis rentré à la maison
enfin c'est pas vraiment ma maison mais
bon à paris france je suis passé par la
case hôtesse d'accueil le temps d'avoir
du temps pour me retourner et pour finir
mon mémoire accessoirement parce que
j'ai pris un peu le temps sur le diplôme
à ce moment là je me suis dit je vais en
profiter pour explorer les trucs qui me
plaisent et un truc là qui m'attire
c'est le l'innovation sociale pour moi
qui me disait je suis pas trop fait
peut-être pour l'entreprise a priori
j'ai besoin d'un boulot qu'à un minimum
de sens c'était peut-être ça la voix
alors j'ai de la chance
au bout de trois mois je trouve un job
dans une boîte une entreprise sociale
justement qui fait de l'accès à
l'énergie
là je suis mais hyper enthousiaste je me
dis ça y est c'est ça je trouve est sauf
qui se passe un truc que j'avais pas du
tout mais alors pas du tout anticipé du
jour au lendemain ça part en vrille
du jour au lendemain je découvre qu'il
ya un vide abyssal entre ce qu'on dit et
ce qu'on fait et ça ça ça me heurte sam
heurte au point que ça me rend malade
littéralement je démissionne
là j'ai 25 ans j'ai plus envie de
travailler
alors je sais pas si vous vous avez déjà
vécu ça ce truc qui fait qu'on n'arrive
pas à se lever le matin qu'on peut plus
je peux vous dire que c'est sacrément
flippant c'est flippant parce qu'au fond
on sait qu'on peut pas faire autrement
ça c'est une illustration de ce que ces
parcours non linéaire peuvent créer
comme questionnement comme tension au
niveau des individus est la question que
ça pose c'est si c'est ça le futur
comment on fait comment on fait pour
apprendre à naviguer dans un monde du
travail qui est incertain alors certes
la question exposé aux décideurs aux
pouvoirs publics aux entreprises
mais se pose avant tout à chacun d'entre
nous parce que moi je pense qu'on peut
et même qu'on doit avant tout agir là où
on est là où on peut c'est nous alors je
vous ai laissé sur la crise des 25 ans
c'était il ya quatre ans ça va mieux
j'ai pris une petite année où j'ai fait
du free lance j'ai bossé comme sa droite
à gauche je me suis posé des questions
puis au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
en fait ça fait quand même longtemps
anaïs que tu as a dans les tripes envie
d'entreprendre donc vas-y en parallèle
il y avait de plus en plus de gens
autour de moi qui me posait ses
questions sur le travail donc je voyais
que ça devenait un vrai enjeu de société
donc c'est là que j'ai initié so many
ways une association qui avait vocation
à adresser c'est cette problématique de
la transformation du rapport au travail
et de ses conséquences sur notre société
alors là pas du tout en train de vous
dire que l'entrepreneuriat c'est la
solution ça j'y crois pas dutroux
je pense que c'est une solution parmi
d'autres qu'elle convient pas à tout le
monde et qu'elle convient pas à chaque
moment de nos vies
je suis pas non plus en train de vous
dire que j'ai trouvé ma voie au moment
je me suis embarqué dans cette aventure
j'étais pas du tout sur douze chalets
jeu naviguer à vue comme on dit et
aujourd'hui c'est pareil
la seule chose que ça change c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je le vis mieux parce que
je me suis habitué
alors quand on a lancé sommet wise au
départ il y avait eu une intuition
l'intuition c'était que si tous on était
en capacité de naviguer de rebondir de
job englobe non seulement en fonction de
nos besoins nos envies de nos
aspirations
mais également de la réalité du marché
du travail et bien alors on serait plus
agile et ça irait mieux pour tout le
monde ça semble hyper simple évidemment
on ne savait pas du tout par où
commencer
alors on a fait un premier événement on
s'indigne venez on va parler du travail
parce que ça change aujourd'hui ce combi
on était personnes on a lancé une
bouteille à la mer comme ça et en fait
il ya eu 100 personnes qui sont venues à
notre événement
on s'est dit il ya un truc donc on a
continué on a lancé des ateliers
collectifs créatif qu avait vocation à
permettre aux gens de se poser les
bonnes questions et de préparer leur
prochaine étape professionnelle
je vous parle pas de du job parfait du
job de leurs rêves ça non plus j'y crois
pas je vous parle juste de dire qui je
suis où je suis qu'est ce que je sais
faire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la réalité si je
vois un peu plus loin où est ce que
j'aimerais aller et du coup comment je
pars ans alors
aujourd'hui ça fait un petit moment le
temps commence à être au bilan et les
gens nous disent que ça les a aidés
tant mieux on a du mal à appréhender
qu'est-ce qui les a aidées là dedans pas
évident alors le week-end dernier on a
fait une vidéo où on a demandé aux
participants à nos ateliers et aux
bénévoles qui les anime de témoigner et
ce qu'ils ont dit c'est que 1
ça leur permettait d'être moins seul que
quand on se posait toutes ces questions
dans son coin
en fait on avait l'impression qu'on
était bizarre alors qu'en fait c'est un
phénomène de société que deux ça leur
avait permis de mieux comprendre leurs
besoins
aujourd'hui on veut tous le job parfait
avec la bonne peine c'est près de chez
soi les gens sont sympas certes mais de
choisir parmi ça c'est quoi aujourd'hui
qui est le plus important est que du
coup ça leur avait permis de clarifier
leur situation et d'avancer plus
facilement
et puis enfin ils nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient compris qu'ils avaient pas qu'un
seul chemin en fait j'en avais plein et
que du coup bah fallait essayer fallait
avancer fallait mettre un pied devant
l'autre et puis que tant pis si ce
n'était pas la première voie qui
fonctionnait bien il y en aurait une
autre après au final avec tout ça ce
qu'on a compris c'est que pour naviguer
dans un monde professionnel qui est
incertain ce avant tout une question de
connaissance de soi c'est-à-dire de
capacité à comprendre qu'est ce qu'on
aime
qu'est ce qui est important pour nous
comment on fonctionne parce que quand
tout bouge
y a que ça qui restent et deuxièmement
une question de confiance en soi pour
avancer pour oser pour choisir et
pourraient être résiliés puisque c'est
des compétences
la connaissance de soi et la confiance
en soi et bien c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que ça veut dire qu'on peut les
développer alors oui je crois qu'il faut
avant tout que chacun comprenne notre
parcours professionnel en main mais ça
ça veut pas dire que je pense que les
entreprises ont rien à faire dans cette
histoire
au contraire je pense qu'elles ont une
énorme transformation enclenché pour
passer d'une logique où elle cherche à
fidéliser des talents retenir des gens
pour aller vers une logique où elle
cherche à les développer
alors permettre de trouver la place qui
leur correspondent à chaque étape de
leur parcours professionnel et cette
place parfois être en interne parfois
être en externe mais globalement on y
gagnera tous alors évidemment je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin je pense que
enfin je rêve en tout cas du jour où
toutes les entreprises toutes les écoles
et même pôle emploi mettre un petit peu
de sommeil ouest dans leur
accompagnement
on n'en est pas là alors pour conclure
j'aimerais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
oui les intuitions sont confirmés on est
face à un marché du travail qui change
et ça nous concerne tous mais que non on
n'a pas toutes les solutions même n'y a
pas de solution magique n'y a pas de
voie toute tracée
il n'y a pas de chemin unique pour y
arriver et je pense que notre enjeu à
tous c'est de chercher à développer
notre connaissance de soi et notre
confiance en soi c'est ça qui nous
permettra de naviguer dans ce monde du
travail qu'un certain et petit à petit
étape après étape à nous rapprocher
quelque chose qui nous correspond alors
ça ça veut dire se mettre en mouvement
se mettre en mouvement ça veut dire
qu'il y aura des moments où doutera et
du coup j'avais envie de vous laisser
sur une citation personnellement
m'inspire beaucoup
quai de churchill et qui dit le succès
n'est pas final l'échec n'est pas fatale
c'est le courage de continuer qui compte
merci
[Applaudissements]